your travel plans could get more
complicated because of the rising number
of covert cases right now and this
summer and here's a big difference from
previous years you may have more trouble
getting all of your money back if you
test positive
just take a look at airbnb it recently
announced it's dropping cancellation
exceptions for covid that's starting may
31st which means a host's original rules
will apply
cbs news senior travel advisor peter
greenberg is here with how to navigate
coveted concerns while you travel peter
good morning uh there are a lot of copa
concerns uh and a lot of it has to do
with these cancellations which people
sometimes buy insurance for thinking
they're doing good by themselves what's
the story with travel insurance well i
love the concept of travel insurance
it's the execution where you have a
problem and during the last two and a
half years it was the largest number of
complaints from from travelers because
if you make your reservations online and
so many people do you cannot finish the
transaction unless you either opt in or
opt out of the insurance and most people
with the best of intentions starting in
2019 picked the option to go in i always
opt out well you did the right thing
they did it but they had no idea what
they were covered for and worse they had
no idea what they were not covered for
and then of course the pandemic hits
their trip gets canceled they go to use
their insurance and they find out that
let's say somewhere on the website of
the insurance company which was never
displayed on the website when they when
they made the reservation was a
paragraph that said oh by the way we
don't cover from pandemic buh-bye
so millions of dollars were lost
and basically people were out their
money wow so they bought worthless
insurance and they didn't get the
cancellation so is there a good time to
buy but i'm a person i don't buy the
warranty if i'm renting a car i don't
get the extra whatever that comes with
that
but are there times that you actually
should get the insurance absolutely but
you need to know
how to get it and where to get it from
don't buy it online don't buy it from
the travel provider themselves because
many of them self-insure so if they go
out of business so does your insurance
you go through a third party go to a
travel agent a travel advisor they can
walk you through the hieroglyphics of
that policy language so you know what
the exclusions are because every policy
has an exclusion there are age
exclusions there are pre-existing
medical inclusions there are even
destination exclusions if the united
states government says it's a level four
don't go
your vacation to syria will not be
covered so you have
you you get the cops yes yeah yeah the
point is go through that route and
you'll be you'll be protected now the
cost of that is about six to ten percent
of the cost of your trip and then it's
worth it as long as you know what you're
covered for as well as what you're not
covered tony mentioned covet and how it
complicates travel maybe not as much as
it used to uh most countries don't
require to test anymore the u.s does but
it's it's a bit complicated what do you
need to tell travelers about covet tests
in traveling well the good news is most
countries have gotten rid of the
requirement for testing if you can show
proof of vaccination so you get to go in
without that
there are no quarantine rules anymore as
long as you prove a vaccination the
problem is getting back home right now
the u.s still has a rule in place that
you shall have a show a negative cova
test within 24 hours of your return
flight to be able to come back to the
united states other countries have
dropped that there's a huge move on to
get the united states to drop it too for
reciprocity reasons doesn't matter where
you go
you've got to get it you've got to get
it you've got to get back in the people
that review it though are the airline
employees it's not a public health
authority and one thing i'll just point
out from that graphic it says 24 hours
it's one calendar day right so if you're
flying late in the day and you think
about it you get confused about that
confused it's important you have more
flexibility than you think it's one
calendar day from your departure date
right now there's another kind of
insurance everybody really needs to have
okay and that's medical evacuation and
repatriation insurance because your
medical coverage in the united states
doesn't cover you when you go overseas
your health insurance what is medical
evacuation it means that if you get sick
or injured overseas in the best policies
they'll pay to get you stabilized over
there they'll consult with your own
doctor who knows your medical history
better than your physician and then if
needed they will fly you back on a
medically equipped jet to the doctor and
medical facility of your choice
get that medical exactly because
recently we've seen some actual deaths
at resorts
when people were traveling on vacation
right well not just the deaths i saw a
guy in cairo one day who decided to
stupidly try to climb the pyramids he
fell down broke his hip he had to be
taken home he didn't have the insurance
they had to buy four first-class tickets
to put the stretcher in a fifth first
class ticket for the nurse they required
to have with him his airfare costs alone
were 87 thousand dollars whoa so you
need to get that that view was priceless
though i i would have been that guy i
got to say i relate
to your arm and leg literally you're
trying to get back in you test positive
how long do you have to stay in that
country well the good news is their
insurance policies now the market's
adjusting where you will get covered if
you have to get tested positive and
they'll pay for your expenses while
you're quarantined all right peter
greenberg thank you always good advice
and always good to see you you got it